who's on the phone fritzy he says his
name is Ernest from Ernest Ernest from
Atlanta hey artist I am a longtime
listener first-time caller
yeah yeah do you work do you work with a
couple of knuckleheads at night Johnson
of TNT hi Ernie thank you for calling
I'm doing great now I had some dark dark
years I saw the attention you got a
couple years ago and I wanted to double
down and get a little bit of that yeah
yeah that cancer longer yeah look I I
saw that I actually I saw a couple of
things I saw the first thing I saw
yesterday was the nice stuff he said
about our show which we which was really
really cool and then I had no idea until
later that that you would talk about
what you've been dealing but for seven
years man and I just um I can't tell you
how much respect I have for you how and
look I know how difficult that is even
though what we do this stuff on the air
for a living but it's hard to talk about
yourself and and being honest about
things that you're facing and and the
way you did it was just so so honest and
so classy and so you know it's so
heartfelt and and man I just want you to
know how much we're all supporting you
and that you know prayers up for you man
because doing what you do for that long
a time each day and then to be dealing
for seven years with something that
doesn't make you feel a hundred percent
I mean I can't imagine how you how you
pulled that off and you certainly fooled
me man because when we were at the Final
Four and I was on your show but you know
across from the arena that was it was
such a cool day and I told my our PR
guys afterwards isten that
show us so much fun to do because we're
at the final four and never once in ten
or fifteen minutes did we talk about the
Final Four we talked about how cool it
is to do what we do and how and thought
about mistakes we've made on the air and
laughed about it and and man it just it
just came back to me that dance and how
fortunate we are how blessed we are to
be doing what we're doing and and you
meant so much to so many people through
the years and I know you'll you know
you'll get this behind you at me
you know it's smooth sailing but for you
to come out like you did and talk about
that and and also to encourage people
that look don't be scared of what the
doctor might say go you know make sure
everything's okay you know go and so
you're a great example and and I love
you brother I really do and I man I just
I I have so much admiration for you yeah
I'm gonna stop being so sad okay
Thank You Ernie I mean I've been nicer
if Shaq or Charles cata called in but
look it's it's still it's still nice I
mean I'll take what I can get you know
even Kenny but ya know what you know
what I know exactly why Charles isn't
because he's so nervous right now
because this is the day that we play the
black masters here north of Atlanta one
resulted did you not know about this he
dubbed it the black masters we played
the first one last year it was just me
and Chuck and Chico our head of security
and Jerome who's another one of our
friends it was just the four of us and I
won the coveted black jacket now today
today we've increased the field you can
get a whole load of who's gonna be
teeing it up here today in an hour and
ten minutes okay it's it's it's me and
Chuck and Chico as you all know and
Grant Hill and Gary Sheffield
and Chris Weber um I know I'm leaving
somebody out here too but yeah it's like
a like folks who have been on the air at
the Turner so where there's eight of us
or seven of us
Smith was a late scratch hmm for some
for some reason but yeah we'll be up at
shelter Olano here in Brazelton playing
the black masters hey thank you for
reaching out by Charles doesn't call now
Shaq doesn't play right okay but I want
you to tell me this I know you gotta run
but Shaq is seems pretty serious with
Charles about that he's not takin any of
his his his junk here I mean he's it's
like close to go time between these two
people look thought it's close to go
time for a long time but no and I think
this three-day window that we have off
where ESPN and ABC had the games on
Thursday Friday Saturday comes at just
the perfect time so Shaq was a little
frosted the other night with with the
the clock being left very little time
but his explanation of look we're
supposed to go from 1 to 2 to 3 and we
went from 1 to 2 back to warning will
reckoning with me for the rest of my
life
so now nobody's throwing hands on that
initially they're gonna have to deal
with me then okay really you don't want
you don't want any of the smoke I do not
I do not but when I see at the sports
Emmys it might be go time between us
earning between usually yeah might be if
you guys win look I revealed this
condition I revealed this medical
condition right before the Emmys I mean
this is all this is my year you know we
wouldn't have known who's nominated I
know your timing has got to be better
Dan I'm on drugs Ernie that time your
time and dad has got to improve you have
to you have to ask when are the judges
going to be reviewing capes when do they
have to have their votes in and then
the big reveal damn it Paulie you told
me that the votes not in my bad Ernie's
right through this whole thing yesterday
never mind Ernie as you and I both know
very well it's an honor just to be
nominated yes it is yes it is thank you
hey Ernie tell tell Charles I said hello
and his golf swing is making me more
nauseous yeah you know what it's one of
those things you'd like an eclipse you
have to poke a hole in a shoebox Thank
You Ernie that's a Ernie Johnson from
TNT he's been through his own health
issues far more serious than mine four
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR Live or download the Dan
Patrick show at